hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm gerry
today we're gonna be checking out the
trailer for a movie called the walk
official trailer number one hmm you know
this film is directed by robert zemeckis
talented talented filmmaker i wish we
could be filmmakers instead of just
doing reaction reviews that there was a
way where we could also be filmmakers
well there is a way Ryan what if what if
we were if we were to walk we could go
to Full Sail University and learn all
the different tenets of filming wait
wait wait
I feel like I heard at Full Sail
University you probably have what does
it offer I mean they offer various
programs for like film production
digital cinematography screenwriting
they have stuff for like music and
gaming as well that is insane yeah you
know they they have all the tools to
teach you the ins and outs of writing
directing you know shooting
cinematography editing like you know
yeah it seems like pre-production it's
pretty amazing post-production it's
pretty amazing pretty much everything
you need to make a modern film ever
every level from like bachelors up to
masters you know it's like a legit
degree but for filmmaking stuff yeah you
could you could become you could get a
master's degree you know you know yeah
you know I heard that they can get you a
MacBook Pro actually if you have cuz you
can't guarantee a spot but you should
still try oh yeah you know you got a you
know sort of prove yourself you know in
order to get in as it's customary I
think with any film school you know
what's funny we could have just talked
about this like for 30 seconds but we
talked about it for 60 we could have
done it for natural way we could have
let's watch this trailer I'm sure a lot
of us thought wow they're taking a lot
of time to get to the trailer no guy no
one to Full Sail
Wow you can walk really fast yeah first
person would have you adjust accordingly
is it pretty crazy
[Music]
hundred fake miniatures
[Music]
people ask me why do you risk death for
me this is like welcome to New York
anything to declare
I'm going to hang a high wire between
the two towers of the World Trade Center
and Walker huh girl lark no matter where
I was going or what I was doing I was
always searching looking for the perfect
place to hang my wire I need you to help
me pull this off I got just the guys now
it starts I'll figure out how to get the
wire across I think we should wait no
this is extremely illegal not to mention
dangerous
[Music]
I had this flipped out we were next time
to step on the wire I don't know if I'll
be able to take my first step
your heart will tell you to do
the man is obviously crazy we're just
here to watch him die
this isn't a game to be that mean our
mistake out there but you're going to
die
[Music]
I know he makes the play
[Music]
Thunder rec yeah right again
[ __ ] a handle that [ __ ] dude Heights
freaked me out I like to think that I'm
afraid of heights within a reason and
though they're like one of my biggest
fears I have tried many things to
conquer my fear of heights I went on
supreme scream and Knott's Berry Farm
and I have even jumped off a 50-foot
cliff in the water the only times I've
done those I've had the same reaction
most people are like yes I conquer my
fear I was like holy [ __ ] my fear has
amplified how much I am terrified more
of heights I thought I was going to die
before I hit that water when I jump I
remember thinking this is it like I came
to terms with death at that point
watching this is it's pretty interesting
I like watching characters who have like
these strange ambitions and desires but
they like it means so much to them even
though it's like to some people they
just might not get it yeah it's fun to
explore a movie where you will get it
and understand it yeah well it seems
like Zemeckis is a good director for
something like this and I really hope
that the movie kind of matches this tone
because it does feel you know like like
when he's getting to New York there will
be a certain amount of snap yeah also
like when it comes to the actual
planning and the actual you know
building and no gonna walk it seems like
there will be a certain amount of you
know air and Wonder you know that that I
think Robert Zemeckis it's really good
it's really it's recreating that
experience cuz I saw some of the
documentary I loved man on wire I
thought man on wire was really cool yeah
so to be looking at this was like
interesting because I was like oh my god
I'm still scared even though yeah even
though I know everything's gonna be fine
yeah well that's the thing is like I
remember in Man O War when they actually
get to the partn they're showing the
photographs of him just walking like
there is a beauty to that it seems like
especially in IMAX they would be able to
really translate I hope so yeah I hope
so and one thing I want to mention jgl
wasn't distracted by his voice did a
good job there jiggle-jiggle-jiggle what
you go what anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the real rejects you can
subscribe to the channel if you happen
to like us Full Sail
University and you could check out
Jerry's playlist his movie reviews and
dank ass dubs a podcast he does with our
buddy Aaron Full Sail University and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we might get product placement like like
you know the like from Full Sail
University seriously you know if you're
considering a career you know in film
production or screenwriting you know
that might be a way to go because it
seems like I've heard that name more and
more in recent years and like I said
there are a number of filmmakers I
admire who have been through there so I
never very James what is just true I
have heard the name Full Sail few times
like if you're looking you know I'm sure
a lot of people are out there looking to
get acquainted with production pre post
you know all that stuff writing and
that's one of the places to do it you
know so I support this